bonjour à toutes et à tous alors je
raconter une histoire qui m'est arrivé
il ya quelques années dans le cadre d'un
travail en équipe alors c'est à l'époque
où j'étais encore salarié j'avais un
poste où j'avais des responsabilités
très variés pas mal de déplacements
plein de projets en cours en fin c'était
vraiment tout ce que j'aimais et j'avais
une nouvelle collaboratrice qui venait
d'arriver dans mon équipe
elle était vraiment parfaite a été
génial c'était vraiment le binôme dont
j'avais toujours rêvé
on se comprenait super bien j'avais même
pas besoin de parler elle disait dans
mes pensées j'ai eu l'impression enfin
c'était vraiment parfait jeu à tel point
que je me suis dit si je mets en fait
cette société faut absolument qu'elle me
suivent enfin c'était super alors on
n'était pas très bavarde elle était
toujours souriante et puis elle était
super efficace donc ça fonctionnait bien
on avait pas mal de pression des délais
assez courts fallait sauter d'un projet
à un autre mais vu que on travaille bien
ensemble ben en fait on s'en sortait
très très bien c'était génial
donc ça a duré comme ça pendant quelques
semaines jusqu'au jour où j'arrive au
bureau et là un dragon s'est positionné
à la place de ma collaboratrice
explosion tremblement de terre dans le
bureau rien ne va plus en fait ça
n'allait pas du tout
qu'est donc notre relation de travail
n'allait pas du tout j'ai été horrible
alors là autant vous dire que je tourne
de dix étages je reste bouche bée
donc là je comprends vraiment pas je me
dis qu'on n'a pas vécu la même semaine
ou alors elle a un double je ne sais pas
bon donc non seulement je comprends pas
mais en plus je me sens complètement
trahi
donc en réalité ça faisait quelques
temps qu'elle avait des problèmes
personnels elle avait accumulé du stress
au travail aussi et puis elle avait mal
interprété certaines choses que je lui
avais dit
et puis aussi bas ce fonctionnement en
fait de passer d'un sujet à un autre
d'un projet un automne en permanence ça
lui convenait pas vraiment mais en fait
elle avait tellement intériorisé que le
jour où ses sorties pas de chance était
sur moi et franchement c'était vraiment
pas beau à voir
alors quel a été mon erreur dans cette
situation est bien de supposer que
qu'elle avait le même mode de
fonctionnement que moi et visiblement
nous n'avions absolument pas la même
perception de la situation
en effet deux personnes peuvent regarder
la même chose et voir quelque chose de
totalement dit
rang parce que voyez plutôt une jeune
femme ou une personne âgée deux
personnes peuvent vivre la même
situation et réagir de manière
totalement différente
visiblement c'est ce qui m'est arrivé
que ma collaboratrice alors pourquoi
est-ce que la connaissance de soi est
elle importante
alors l'histoire que je viens de vous
raconter est une piste déjà
d'autre part selon l'institut de sondage
gallup plus de 65% des problèmes de
performance d'entreprise pourrait être
résolu en améliorant les relations entre
les employés
ce n'est pas rien alors je vais vous
parler du modèle insight discovery qui
m'a beaucoup aidé dans un premier temps
et puis que je transmets aujourd'hui en
entreprise alors qu'est ce que c'est en
fait c'est un modèle qui est basé donc
sur les théories de carl jung et
notamment ses théories concernant les
types psychologiques qui utilise donc
4energy de couleurs qui vont nous
permettre de comprendre pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fonctionne du certains de manière
et pourquoi est ce que les autres font
différemment alors il n'y a pas une
couleur qui soit meilleure qu'une autre
bien évidemment donc c'est pour ça que
j'en parlerai à chaque fois des énergies
de couleurs à la fois dans leur bonjour
mais aussi dans leurs mauvais jours
commençant dans l'énergie rouge alors
l'énergie routes d'engins bonjour et
déterminé volontaire très orienté
résultats elle est très compétitive et
les personnes qui utilisent beaucoup
cette énergie adore relever des défis
en revanche dans un mauvais jour on peut
trouver les personnes qui utilisent
beaucoup cette énergie un petit peu
autoritaire dirigiste intolérants et ces
personnes qui exige tellement d'elle
même
bacquet l'on attende tout autant des
autres en fait un petit sondage dans la
salle qui se reconnaît dans cette
énergie de couleur à main levée ok
l'énergie verte maintenant alors
l'énergie verte et bienveillante
patiente encourageantes
les personnes qui utilisent beaucoup
cette énergie recherche l'harmonie et
veille toujours à ce que le processus de
prise de décision soit démocratique et
elles ont une très bonne écoute
en revanche à force de toujours chercher
à ne froisser personne
eh bien elles peuvent avoir du mal à
prendre position et tiendront leur est
très difficile et si on ne fait pas
attention alors tendance à tout
intérioriser une simple montée de stress
ou une simple remarque déplacée et elles
peuvent exploser
et là vous retrouver confronté aux
dragons mon histoire qui se reconnaît
dans cette énergie
ok l'énergie jaune maintenant l'énergie
jaune et sociable dynamique enthousiaste
les personnes qui utilisent beaucoup
cette énergie sont multi projets longs
plein d'idées plein de choses en tête
elle aime être au coeur de l'action
alors ils ont plein d'idées certes mais
par contre elles n'ont pas toujours
jusqu'au bout de leur idée parce que la
planification et le suivi des projets
c'est pas vraiment leur forme
et puis elles peuvent facilement cc
distraire ou perdent en concentration
aussi surtout si vous essayez de leur
faire une présentation powerpoint de
quatre heures sur une étude scientifique
rempli de statistiques là c'est sûr
qu'au bout de dix minutes vous les avez
perdu qui se reconnaît dans cette
énergie alors vous inquiétez pas j'ai
pas prévu une présentation de quatre
heures avec plein de statistiques
l'énergie bleue l'énergie bleue et
prudente réfléchi précise méthodique
très organisé les personnes qui
utilisent beaucoup cette énergie pour le
coup elles n'ont pas de mal avec la
planification et suivi des projets et
elles ont un sens aigu du détail
en revanche dans un mauvais jour on peut
trouver le contact initial un petit peu
froid
et puis elles peuvent aussi parfois
poser car elle pose énormément de
questions mais parfois elle s'attache
vraiment à des détails qui ont pas
forcément importance elles peuvent
devenir jusqu'à suspicieuse et elles
peuvent être indécise aussi
qui se retrouve dans cette énergie de
couleurs ok alors il est très important
il est important de connaître en fait
les caractéristiques de chaque énergie
de couleur individuellement car elles
sont distinctes on a pu le constater
mais ce qui est vraiment important de se
rappeler c'est que nous sommes un
mélange unique des quatre couleurs et
c'est peut-être pour ça que certains
d'entre vous ont peut-être levé la main
plusieurs fois pendant quand j'ai fait
le sondage
on aura bien évidemment des dominantes
ce qui va vous permettre de reconnaître
plus facilement les préférences de
communication des uns et des autres mais
on utilise bien les quatre énergie dans
une plus ou moins grande mesure fonction
des situations
tout est donc une histoire de préférence
en parlant de préférence je vous
demandais de croiser les bras
vous êtes bien sentais bien
ouais ok parfait donc maintenant je vais
vous demander de croiser les bras dans
le sens inverse avec la main opposée qui
passe au dessus
aulas s'avère plus compliqué
[Musique]
comment vous sentez moins bien ok
donc c'est exactement ça le concept de
préférence c'est à dire que je vous
demande de croiser les bras vous mettez
dans la position qui est la plus
confortable pour vous quand je vous
demande de le faire dans le sens inverse
vous y parvenez alors c'est plus ou
moins facile pour certains mais vous y
arrivez par contre je vous lève comme ça
et on parle d'autre chose pendant 10
minutes vous allez automatiquement vous
mettre dans une position qui est
confortable et bien c'est pareil avec
les énergies de couleurs c'est à dire
que vous utiliserez vos énergies de
couleur préférée de manière très
confortable et pour ce qui est des
autres
eh bien vous vous arriverez à les
utiliser mais ça vous demandera plus
d'efforts alors si on prend cet exemple
c'est un de mes anciens patrons
on voit qu'il a une préférence très
marqué pour l'énergie rouge l'énergie
rousseil 20 95% fait pas mal et puis une
préférence aussi pour l'énergie jaune
donc ces deux énergies de couleurs il y
parvient il arrive à les utiliser de
manière très confortable
par contre en ce qui concerne les
énergies vertes et bleues c'est pas
vraiment son fort donc du coup il pourra
les utiliser mais ça va lui demander un
petit peu plus d'efforts alors quand je
collaborais avec lui eh ben déjà j'avais
droite au but quand j'ai quelque chose à
lui demander je passais pas par quatre
chemins et j'ai essayé aussi de ne pas
changer de sujet de manière totalement
décousu chose que je peux avoir tendance
à faire je ne me formalise et pas quand
je recevais des mails de sa part sans
formes sont ni bonjour ni au revoir je
savais que ce n'était pas de
l'impolitesse c'était juste la manière
de fonctionner et j'ai vite et aussi de
lui de l'assaillir de mails de
paperasserie et de détails parce que
j'ai très vite compris que ce n'était
pas son truc et que si je voulais une
réponse rapide à mes demandes il valait
mieux un petit coup de fil
plutôt qu'un long mais l'interminable
bon voilà alors l'idée étant pas de se
changer bien évidemment mais juste de
mettre un tout petit peu en veilleuse
nos préférences de communication et
d'utiliser un tout petit peu plus celle
de l'autre pour mieux répondre à ses
attentes à ses besoins alors quand est
ce que ça peut vous servir dans la vie
et bien tout moment où la relation est
présente que ce soit aujourd'hui dans
vos groupes de travail avec d'autres
étudiants et vos professeurs que ce soit
demain dans votre vie professionnelle
quand vous allez travailler en équipe
avec vos managers avaient
vos clients et puis un peu à tout moment
dans votre vie privée aussi avec votre
famille vos amis à tout moment la
relation est présente en poche un petit
peu plus sur mes préférences de
communication et celle des autres j'ai
vraiment pu petit à petit apprécier les
personnes qui étaient complètement
différente de moi et ainsi pouvoir
bénéficier de la complémentarité de nos
modes de fonctionnement
ça m'a permis des collaborations plus
efficace et moins de risque de me
retrouver face aux dragons du début
alors si vous aussi vous n'avez pas
envie un jour de vous retrouver face à
lui je vous conseille vivement d'oser
partir à la découverte de vous même et
des autres doses et comprendre et
apprécier les différents chez autrui
vous y adapter pour mieux travailler
ensemble et mettre en place des
relations plus harmonieuses
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]